wildfires are burning unchecked and out
of control across Nova Scotia destroying
homes and sending people fleeing for
their lives
at least 16 000 people have been
evacuated and hundreds of structures
including houses have been incinerated
towering clouds of smoke could be seen
in cell phone video taken aboard a
passenger jet officials say they believe
the fires were very likely caused by
humans a result of campfires getting out
of control
it's so very very dry and on that point
I'd like to take this opportunity to
remind everyone of the importance of not
burning the province has banned all
travel and outdoor activities including
camping hiking and fishing the forests
are simply too dry the conditions are
too volatile we can't accept any more
risk of additional of additional fires
Clouds Of Smoke From The Burning Woods
have moved South into the U.S in
Massachusetts a choking Haze blanketed
towns the murky air and a campfire-like
odor reached New York City officials
there and in other cities declared air
quality alerts
urging vulnerable people to stay inside
meanwhile Nova scotia's Premier Tim
Houston says the province desperately
needs more equipment more firefighters
more resources we want and we need and
we will take all the support we gets the
best hope is for a break in the weather
several days of showers are forecast
beginning on Friday Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera